فكره انما صارت تنسيق الامني والتسويه لم
يحقق لشعبنا الا الفشل والدمار
[موسيقى]
الجزيره اهلا بكم
حركه حماس تعرض لاول مره سلاح الجندي
الاسرائيلي هذا الرجل الاسير لديها موضوع
عام 2014
ورئيس الحركه في قطاع غزه يحيى سنوار يمهل
الاحتلال وقتا محدودا لاتمام صفقه تبادل
الاسرى وذلك خلال كلمته لمناسبه ذكرى
الخامسه والثلاثين لتاسيس الحركه ويدعوا
السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني وقت التنسيق
الامنيه مع اسرائيل
في احداث هجوم روسيين على كيف الجيش
الاوكراني يعلن اسقاط 13
[موسيقى]
الامريكي
على خلفيه مخاوف من امكانيه استخدام
التطبيق للتجسس على الامريكيين وفرض رقابه
على المحتوى
الارجنتينيه ليونيل ميسي يؤكد ان نهائيه
مونديال قطر سيكون اخر مباراه له في
بطولات كاس العالم وذلك بعد ان حسنا منتخب
بلاده بطاقه العبور الاولى الى النهائي
بعد فوزه على نظيره الكرواتي لثلاثيه
نظيفه في مباراه مثيره تالق فيها ميسي
الذي سجل هدفا وصنعها هدفا اخر
الى اللقاء